aujourd'hui le haut commissaire à la
réforme des retraites jean paul delevoye
a reçu les syndicats pour leur parler de
la grande réforme des retraites du
quinquennat il va sans doute falloir
travailler plus longtemps mais est ce
que c'est forcément un drame
on en parlera on parlera aussi du sommet
de la francophonie de la francophonie ça
se passe à erevan ça commence demain le
président de la république s'est envolée
pour la capitale de l'arménie
la francophonie est ce que ça sert
encore à quelque chose aujourd'hui mais
on va s'interroger sur ce sujet et puis
on vous parlera de ce scandale révélé
par le canard enchaîné le patron de
force ouvrière pascal pavageau en tout
cas son entourage a fait des fiches
assez renseignée et pas forcément
aimable sur tous les cadres dirigeants
du syndicat
est-ce qu'il doit démissionner ou est-ce
qu'il peut rester en place vous nous
donnerez votre point de vue je vous
présente tout de suite les quatre
invités qui ont accepté d'être là
aujourd'hui
bonjour les lahidji vous êtes avocate
femme politique vous avez été sénatrice
de paris avec l'étiquette europe
écologie les verts vous êtes présidente
d'association de l'association huit
impacts qui se mobilisent pour l'impact
du réchauffement climatique
damien le guay et la bonsoir vous êtes
philosophe essayiste maître de
conférences à h c'est votre dernier
livre la guerre civile qui vient est
déjà là a été publié aux éditions du
cerf bonsoir frédéric saint clair vous
êtes analyste politique vous avez été un
collaborateur de dominique de villepin
quand il était premier ministre
vous collaborez régulièrement au figaro
aux écossais d'ailleurs je crois est
votre dernier livre la droite face à
l'islam a été publié aux éditions
salvator
puis vincent eu lieu et elle a aussi bon
soir à vous accueillir vous êtes grand
reporter au service international de
l'express où est notamment un très grand
spécialiste de l'afrique
votre dernier livre qui est une
biographie de kadhafi a été publié chez
perrin et vous enseigner à l'école
supérieure de journalisme et à sciences
po
on commence par ce premier sujet la loi
sur les faits que news a été adoptée à
l'assemblée nationale je vous en
rappelle le principe
le juge des référés
pour être saisie d'informations
manifestement fausse diffusé pendant les
campagnes électorales et le juge pourra
très vite intervenir par exemple pour
des références et les sites internet qui
diffusent ce genre d'image est ce que
tout ça est une bonne idée
ou est-ce que c'est dangereux il y en a
qui tu pas vraiment d'accord avec cette
loi et c'est le moins qu'on puisse dire
c'est jean luc mélenchon pour lui c'est
carrément dangereux regardez il en a
parlé
cette nuit à l'assemblée c'est une très
mauvaise plaisanterie
le magistrat est à lui seul la qualité
de fausses informations ils décident en
48 heures il n'y a pas de possibilité
d'appel des sillons terrifiante un type
tout seul ou une femme tout seul dfid et
on ne peut même pas faire appel alors on
se souvient que c'est le président bahaa
publique emmanuel macron qui avait voulu
cette fois notamment après les fausses
nouvelles qui avaient couru pendant la
campagne présidentielle c'est elle qui
par exemple lui
donnait des comptes bancaires à
l'étranger ce qui s'est révélé être
complètement faux vincent et je hais ce
que vous partagez le l'inquiétude de
jean luc mélenchon est ce qu'elle est
dangereuse cette loi non je n'ai pas son
sens aigu de l'hyperbole donc je m'en
tiens à ce constat élémentaires qui est
que vouloir légiférer sur ce qui porte
sur la désinformation d'information
revient à peu près à épousseter le
désert du sahara ou à vider l'océan avec
un dé à coudre
pourquoi parce que vous vous heurtez à
deux évidences 1
le degré de sophistication des
machineries d'intox est telle
qu'aujourd'hui ce n'est pas une oie avec
les limites qui ont été énoncées au
d'autres sur lesquelles on viendra sans
doute qui va y mettre un terme
et puis il ya quand même un autre
phénomène que je trouve assez troublant
la matière c'est que s'ils voulaient
quand on regarde le texte en question on
s'aperçoit que légiférer c'est aussi
alimenter les thèses complotistes dire
que vous allez évidemment donné du
carburant à ceux qui disent on ou
bayonne on nous empêche voyez ça c'est
l'establishment et certains ont fait
taire parce qu'on dit la vérité alors
liberticide je reviens sur ce mot qui
est très en vogue
vous savez à la différence notable des
piles vander la liberté de la presse ne
s'use que si l'on ne s'en sert pas dire
que c'est parce que des journalistes et
des citoyens seront exigeants en la
matière que l'on n'aura pas ce qui se
joue en ce moment au brésil
il est utile d'aller jeter un oeil là
bas où le grand quotidien globo a relevé
une cinquantaine de grossières fait nous
y paraît qu'il faut dire un fox en bon
français alors que c'est déjà là aussi
un anglicisme mais passons avec des
éléments aussi grotesques mais qui ont
pesé sur le succès électoral en tout cas
1er 2 sur 2 gelabale sonar haut que le
pt le parti des travailleurs donc dont
le candidat fernando haddad est en
quelque sorte la doublure un peu
pâlichonne
lula incarcéré et bien souhaite
enseigner un kit gay on a vu ça ailleurs
on l'a entendu aussi à l'école primaire
diffuser des tétines en forme de pénis
ou données la gestion des enfants de
plus de cinq ans pour le choix de leur
genre sexuel à l'état et tout ça ça
passe quelques commentaires de
d'internautes sur twitter ou sur
lefigaro.fr sur le sol jean de
chansonnettes cet internaute nous dit
c'est une volonté de museler la presse
n'importe quel candidat pourra faire
n'importe quoi il criera à la fec news
dès que son cas sera cité on vous a
interrogé d'ailleurs sur twitter vous
pouvez vous pouvez voter pour savoir si
selon vous la loi contre les faits que
news et protectrice ou liberticide
pour l'instant c'est 50-50 donc d'où
l'intérêt de ce débat pour vous aider à
vous faire une opinion
si vous n'avez pas encore de point de
vue bien arrêtée sur ce sujet est mort
de chez nous dit le but de cette loi et
d'empêcher toute critique efficace du
gouvernement par les médias alternatifs
et les réseaux sociaux
frédéric 5la votre point de vue sur ce
sujet alors une fois n'est pas coutume
mais l'intellectuel conservateur que je
suis est d'accord avec jean luc
mélenchon il y as au mieux une inutilité
parce qu'un manque de moyens pour qu'une
telle loi si elle était pilotée par
quelqu'un de réellement intelligent soit
efficace mais en plus de ça je pense que
les effets pervers d'une loi comme celle
là où on confond les fins et les moyens
finalement va ou peut amener à une
cacophonie un embourbement de la justice
un poids beaucoup trop importants
accordés aux juges dans une campagne
électorale parce que c'est cette période
là de la vie politique est ciblé en
priorité et on a vu que le sur pouvoir
des juges en campagne électorale pouvait
détruire un candidat on attend encore le
jugement sur françois fillon rappelant
le maquereau mis en examen fondre et à
30% d'opinions positives et on est
encore en train d'attendre de savoir ce
qu'il en est des deux costume de
monsieur france
une enquête n'est pas bouclé bon donc je
dis juste que les campagnes électorales
j'aimerais plutôt qu'on ait une sorte de
suspension du jugement moral parce que
finalement c'est bien de ça dont on
parle quand on parle de fenioux ce qu'il
décide de ce qui est vrai de ce qui est
faux dans l'absolu monsieur mélenchon se
soulève un point important en 48 heures
on doit se prononcer via le fait en lui
même n'est jamais incriminant tiens il
ya derrière autre chose il ya il ya une
façon de le présenter il ya un ensemble
d'éléments concordants discordants peu
importe mais concrètement qu'est ce
qu'on a pour juger et ensuite comment on
va faire pour museler
vous l'avez dit en introduction bien
évidemment que les réseaux sociaux vont
se mobiliser en modifiant plus ou moins
la nouvelle contournant les
interdictions évidemment mettra ici je
me tourne vers l'avocate est ce qu'on a
raison de se méfier des juges est-ce
qu'on a raison d'une manière générale à
un pouvoir il faut toujours un
contre-pouvoir effectivement je
considère que cette loi n'a
objectivement pas beaucoup d'utilité eu
égard à la technicité des process pour
les faits que nous et ça pose également
un autre problème je suis pas forcément
sur la ligne politique de jean luc
mélenchon mais je rejoins un peu son
inquiétude sur le côté liberticide
cette possibilité est réelle mais
au-delà de ça il y à la question de
comment le juge va interpréter la fecq
news alors je je je peux vous assurer
que pour les magistrats et les avocats
d'une manière générale et les magistrats
l'interprétation et rende une décision
ça peut paraître simple sur le pâté
qu'est ce qu'une fine aux mets de
l'appliquer juridiquement puisqu'une
sanctions n'interviendra que c'est là le
délit est constitué si on reconnaît
effectivement la fecq nous mais après
une élaboration et un process d'analysé
très compliqué d'un point de vue
juridique
et comme le focus encore une fois c'est
souvent le problème dans notre pays
c'est qu'on veut légiférer sur une
réaction est là typiquement c'est la loi
du président de la république et ont été
victimes de fake nous considère que
c'est une urgence absolue
il faut faire effectivement attention à
ne pas tomber dans la diffamation on
doit toujours trouver un juste équilibre
en ce qui concerne cette loi mais je
suis toujours plus ou moins quatre
contre
d'une manière générale la politique
l'exécutif le législatif commence à
s'occuper de la liberté de la presse et
de l'histoire d'une manière générale il
ya une vraie part de subjectivité chez
le juge ça je peux en témoigner comme
directeur de journal il ya il ya déjà
des propos qui sont considérés alors je
prends par exemple
des propos qui ont été tenus par eric
zemmour on n'était pas dans le figaro
magazine mais qui en première instance
ont été considérés comme de l'incitation
à la haine raciale et on appelle le juge
a dit bah non c'est sa liberté
d'expression de le dire donc donc c'est
pas facile
d'ailleurs une fausse nouvelle c'est pas
toujours ce qu'on croit je vais vous
passez la parole damien le guay mais
écoutez d'abord un autre député de la
france insoumise mobiliser contre cette
loi c'est alexis corbière lui dit ben la
fausse nouvelle
il y en a certaines qui sont pas dénoncé
alors que pourtant elles sont réelles et
il pense très fort à emmanuel macron
figurez vous regardez le phénomène
majeur en matière de presse lors de
l'élection présidentielle c'est pas ce
que ce pique nique de manière
confidentielle a dit emmanuel macron
c'est ce que 100% et mais n'y en aurait
pas tes d'emmanuel macron qu'il était le
seul candidat en capacité de battre
madame le pen qui était le seul candidat
à pouvoir apporter de réponse en ce pays
alors damien le guay évidemment à lui a
préféré que ce soit que jean luc
mélenchon et était l'homme quand
capacité de faire battre madame le pen
mais là on est sûr de l'analyse
politique
mais quand même quand par exemple on dit
jean luc mélenchon et des comptes
offshore à l'étranger que lui dément
balla et c'est pas illogique que le juge
puisse dire d'arrêter c'est pas vrai
vous n'avez pas le droit de dire ça ce
qui est très fort très compliqué c'est
de savoir ce qui est vrai et ce qui est
faux mais à partir du moment où vous
aviez le philosophe qui commence c'est
pour ça que mes invités je sais pourquoi
je me permets de prendre un peu de
hauteur
qu'est ce qui est vrai qu est ce qui est
faux nous savons tous quand on a fait un
peu d'histoire de l'office de filles ou
même quand on a regardé un tout petit
peu ce que disait rémois ont déjà d'en
avant la guerre que tout récit
historique est un mélange entre des
réalités que l'on connaît et puis une
interprétation une conception des choses
donc les deux vont toujours ensemble il
ya toujours un récit et des faits donc à
partir de quel moment est ce que on peut
déterminer qu'une information est fausse
soit effectivement elle n'a jamais été
prononcé de façon d'une autre soit elle
est pour partie vrai pour partie fausse
un peu interprété de façon d'une autre
et donc très difficile son outil de dire
ce qu'il en est premier premiers points
2e point quand on voit effectivement ce
qui s'est passé pour l'élection de trump
trump tous les médias étaient contre lui
tous les médias n'ont pas arrêté en
permanence pendant sa campagne de dire
que ceci était faut que ceux-ci étaient
faut que ceux-ci étaient faux et ça n'a
pas empêché malgré ça d'être élu donc
quelle est la capacité qu'ont les
électeurs de pouvoir accepter cette part
de fo de vraisemblable de deux
condamnations par les juges etc pour
élire quelqu'un et puis troisième chose
qui me paraît plus important c'est que
si notre démocratie souffrait de cela ça
serait parfait
le vrai problème c'est que les journaux
ne sont pas crédibles
les français le disent les français le
répète les hommes politiques ne sont pas
crédibles
la parole publique n'est pas entendue
elle n'est pas crédible donc le premier
travail me semble-t-il à faire si on
veut redonner du sens à la politique et
aux informations et à ce que peuvent
dire les journaux ces deux d'une façon
ou d'une autre de rendre crédible tout
cela et pourquoi est ce que les journaux
ne sont pas crédibles
parce que pour partie celui répètent
tous à la même chose et donc il ya
quelque chose qui effectivement alors
disons un bruit unique qui condamne et
effectivement vous parliez de d'eric
zemmour qui condamne ce jalon frais qui
condamne ceux qui disent autre chose
donc la question c'est plus l'écosystème
me semble-t-il que cet élément
particulier et puis dans ce que disait
dans ce que disait au moment où
effectivement elles étaient auditionnés
madame nissen
elle insistait beaucoup et sa ministre
de la culture mais la culture aux
mendiants proches qui soutient ce projet
et au moment où elle a annoncé
effectivement que les étaient ses
intentions est ce qu'elle voulait faire
elle a beaucoup insisté sur l'éducation
il faut effectivement que dans les
classes ou d'une façon générale
l'éducation à la
l'information numérique et ça c'est une
excellente idée quand la machine j'ai
alors les journaux sont ils crédibles
alors maintenant si tu savais qu'on peut
être on peut parfaitement être crédible
sans être cru et c'est un peu la
tragédie de nombreux médias honorable
aujourd'hui c'est à dire que pour des
raisons qui tiennent aussi aux erreurs
qui ont été commises par les
journalistes et par les directeurs
rédaction les médias et les acteurs des
médias sont assimilés à une élite
lointaine méprisante et parisienne donc
vous pouvez avoir un article qui est
inattaquable factuellement il n'empêche
que si vous conduisez une enquête
relativement sérieuse en termes de
critères scientifiques vous aurez une
proportion notable de lecteurs qu'ils
considéreront que ceci est biaisé fautes
et les guides etc
je vois dans le texte tel qu'il a été
voté quasiment en catimini
cette nuit quand même d'autres zones
d'ombré d'autres angles morts je voulais
en relever est juste très rapidement
quelques-uns le fameux en période
électorale
moi me trouble beaucoup parce que vous
dire que une heure suffit à séparer le
vis de la vertu les trois mois etc
je ne comprends pas ce qui se joue par
rapport à la construction par rapport à
la déconstruction d'un personnage va
très au delà ou très en deçà des trois
mois donc je ne comprends pas très bien
cette clause temporel le concept ça a
été dit mais manifestement fausse moi
c'est quelque chose qui me laisse
absolument pompeux aloir parce qu'il y
avait eu une fausseté qu'il serait
manifeste une qui serait heureux torse
une qui serait partiel une qui serait
subtil une qui serait grossière je crois
que il ne peut pas y avoir d'instrument
de mesure objective deux objectifs de ce
qui émane est vrai que tu auras
troisième d'un troisième point qui vous
gêne si oui d'accord je termine là
dessus on parle de l'intérieur
l'intervention du juge qu'ils seraient
encadrés mais encadré comment et par qui
et en vertu de quel texte est quelle
philosophie de l'information j'ai
l'intention est sans doute louable
quel que soit le vrai moteur de ce
projet porté par la macro ni mais il y a
tellement de faille à la fois théorique
et pratique
que je pense que c'est un bel exercice
d'unité et bien merci beaucoup je crois
qui à l'unanimité sur ce plateau c'est
assez rare et j'allais dire tant pis on
va laisser le dernier mot à asim sur les
réseaux sociaux qui nous dit à mon avis
avec plein de sagesse de toute façon une
fois que la rumeur est lancée elle est
inarrêtable non c'est une belle
conclusion
on passe à un autre sujet d'actualité du
jour c'est donc la réforme des retraites
c'est l'un des grands projets du
quinquennat emmanuel macron l'a dit il
voudrait unifier les régimes de retraite
avec un système unique par points
le responsable de ce dossier jean paul
delevoye a reçu les syndicats
aujourd'hui pour expliquer un petit peu
ce qu'il voulait faire
l'accueil on va dire que il est il est
assez inégal du côté des syndicats et
coûté deux points de vue d'abord celui
de pascal pavageau
le patron de force ouvrière qui est
assez contre le projet est celui de
laurent berger le patron de la cfdt qui
lui est plutôt pour
pour nous c'est une réforme qui va
détruire les quarante deux régimes
existants pour avoir un régime unique ou
univers